sorride se benvenuti in un nuovissimo b
siamo ormai agli sgoccioli manca
veramente pochissimo a milioni di
iscritti qui su youtube quindi se non
l'avete ancora fatto ricordatevi di
iscrivervi al canale di cliccare sulla
campanella vicino al tasso di iscrizione
per ricevere una notifica tutte le volte
che pubblica un nuovo video in questi
giorni ho sistemato tantissimo
riordinato gli armadi ho fatto il cambio
stagione ho sistemato tutte le messe ore
con i trucchi insomma mi sono data da
fare tutte queste cose le ho fatte
praticamente live insieme a voi perché
mi facevo vedere nelle storie di
instagram fenomi seguite ancora non
volete perdervi questi momenti di vita
quotidiana
seguitemi mentre sistemavo apre un
armadio e vedo praticamente un mostro
composto da tantissimi e jeans guardoni
perché sono i jeans sopra letto quindi
sto sto guardando il nemico alcuni
addirittura credo di non trovarli da
secoli
l'idea di questo video è venuta da
alcuni di voi che mi hanno scritto in
direct sull'iter mai perché non fai un
video in cui trovi questi jeans e come
al solito i mariners chiedono e marina
risponde quindi bando alle ciance
partiamo subito con il primo paio di
jeans
allora per riuscire a farvi vedere al
meglio i jeans non trovano tante
inquadrature quindi li vedrete così e
poi prevedere
diciamola la parte più in fondo mi
mettono sopra questo scadente sgabello
che cosa non si fa per i mariners prima
categoria il games sono quei pantaloni
che sono così stretti ed elasticizzanti
che sembrano appunto dei dei leggings ma
sono appunto con tessuto jeans e
soprattutto hanno la zip e il bottone
che li differenzia dai pantacollant
normali questi qui sono vecchissimi
celebrò presi v dieci anni fa di
abercrombie mi ricordo che quando mi
sono trasferita qui a milano abercrombie
era tipo i brand più fashion
l'evento come i come tutti i geni che si
rispettino
ovviamente sono super stretti questo
modello mi piaceva così tanto dei tempi
avevo preso in questi due queste due
nuove su questo qua un po più scura il
modello esattamente lo stesso e cavolo
andava di moda alla vita bassa adesso
siamo abituate a delle vite un po più
alte o comunque se sono basten non
skinny particolare infatti non lo metto
da po di anni
mamma mia dai jacking siamo passati ai
super skinny così super skinny che a
fatica respiro questi sono invece di
ricerche sono a vita alta come potete
vedere è una 34 che di base è la mia
taglia ma mi sembrano veramente tipici
sono così quindi veramente segnano
tantissimo diciamo che se dovete andare
a pranzo dalla nonna forse non sono i
jeans pirati perché dopo il primo
antipasto dove resa charlie tutte le
ragazze bassine all'ascolto avranno
comprato almeno una volta la loro vita
un jeans per bambini ecco questo è un
gisti ralph lauren tagli a 12 anni
se devo essere sincero non l'ho messo
tanto bisogna scaletta dei sogni 1 e 2
più che altro perché in fondo vedete non
è su perfetto e quindi mi dava fastidio
come come cadeva sulla caviglia ecco
questo mi dava fastidio
comunque sto facendo dinnazi hanoa hanoa
no 11 anni come sentirsi giovani e a
proposito di vita bassa penso che le
tacche minuti e giù che purtroppo mi si
vede le mutande penso che questi siano i
vincitori del premio vita bassa questi
sono di scout che un negozio che c'è qui
a milano
cadono così però non lo utilizzo tanto
per colpa di questa vita bassa che si un
po è tornata però siamo ancora siamo
ancora in transizione tra di tantissima
erika bassissima sensazione nel limbo
led e di mezzo
allora questo è un jeans che ho preso
forse uno degli ultimi che ho preso è di
zara e come potete vedere mi ha colpito
particolarmente per queste borchiette
che ci sono ai lati che fanno molto
rock'n'roll
non ho tantissimi jeans neri noi alta ne
ho qualcuno però non lo so perché quando
io penso al jeans e quando e devo
indossare jeans prediligo i jeans
classico quindi blu e il nero lo metto
un po meno vedete anche questi sono
super skinny a fine video che accadrà si
può sempre parte del team neri questo
qui sempre di zara che nero liscio
quindi senza bordi senza niente a vita
un po più alta e diciamo che questo qua
il modello di zara che utilizzo più
spesso c'era infatti in vari colori e
quello nero come detto prima è quello
che ho messo di meno forse per il fatto
che appunto indossando tanto il neo in
generale il jeans mi aiuta a spezzarlo
anche qui vi faccio vedere come veste
faccia step intanto e1 e2 andiamo a
questo è un rischio amato messo
tantissimo ovviamente un po meno fa
parte ovviamente dalla categoria
i militari è un po tamarra etto però mi
piace mi piace sotto per queste tasse
mi fa molto tomb raider è infatti se non
erro avevo utilizzato per una festa di
carnevale in cui mi ero ovviamente
vestita da tomb raider
avevo questi qui con dentro le pistole
delle tante c'è ma di cosa stiamo
parlando di coach zurek è sempre nella
categoria i militari c'è lui che un
periodo più stretti e infatti faccio
fatica a fare lo scalino anche questo le
alle cerniere le tasse o le cerniere un
po più skinny questo qui è diversa e un
po più pesante proprio come come tessuto
passiamo al sobrio che ovviamente
avevate qualche dubbio è uno dei miei
preferiti rigorosamente maculato skinny
anche questo vita alta comunque oltre
sono in tutto il video bene mi avrebbe
lasciato cioè poli e rimetti e strizza e
chiudi fosse in casa
entriamo nella categoria boyfriend
boyfriend che un jeans che andava stato
in moto degli anni 90 quindi dritto ma
insomma non skinny ma neanche a zampa
quindi scende deferito vita semi alta e
mi piace molto ha davanti
non mi fa impazzire dietro perché
appiattisce un po lo so non so se mi
spiego
cioè non nove decimi chicche che segnano
un po è questo qua invece rimane dritto
sul didietro però è il modello fatto
così quindi della serie se non ti piace
non comprarlo no ma siamo una categoria
che amo tantissimo i jeans a zampa
d'elefante quindi vita alta aderenti
fino a diciamo il ginocchio e poi da lì
si aprono le acque questi sono di zara
gli omessi intanto anche ultimamente mi
piace molto il fatto che siano l'area di
sotto perché io indosso spesso gli
stivali col tacco il segreti col tacco e
qui sotto sono perfetti perché per noi
ragazze non è stato
sì me se tu ti metti il pantalone a
zampa chi lo sa che ai tacchi sotto
nessuno quindi sembri un metro e ottanta
e nessuno saprà mai la verità
passiamo ai prodotti rotti perché non so
voi ma catania di calda sotto qualizza
la forza di tirarli su io puntualmente
rompe e puntualmente mi ritrovo questi
buchi enormi nei jeans
vi sembra normale poi ci sono questi
sempre di zara che sono skinny e che io
li chiamo i fastidiosi perché perché
restare li vedete qua questi strappi che
ci sono alla fine io puntualmente quando
ve li infilo mi si incastra la luce
dentro e c'è una guerra per far uscire
la luce da questo strappo quindi per
quello dico sono i fastidiosi e poi c'è
lui che è la vita così tanto alta che
fra un po mi fa da reggiseno avete mai
visto una una vita così alta
comunque lui è di h m anche questo lo ha
messo un botto perché si abbina bene
praticamente a tutto
vital tacchini passiamo una categoria
che io amo e cioè i jeans strappati ecco
questi più che strappati sono aperti ad
evitare da quanto adesso che sono
macchiati questi sono tipo dei boy
friend che hanno fatto la guerra
e a proposito di strappati neanche loro
scherzano un po più skinny e melo
boyfriend ma anche qua cioè vabbè ma qua
pensa aspetta forse poi mi sono aperti
dopo c'è qua sono strappati ok ma qui
magari erano chiusi così e io forza di
fare ginnastica quei jeans e io
eccoci arrivati alla fine del video
spero tantissimo che vi sia piaciuto mi
raccomando fatemi sapere con un
commentino qui sotto quali tra cui
i jeans avete preferito o pensate che mi
stiano meglio i quali invece magari
proprio non vi piacciono
vi ricordo di iscrivervi al canale se
non avete ancora fatto e di seguire vi
sia su in serata e su tik tok per
coltiva mente sto pensando tantissimi
video e contenuti anche io vi mando un
bacione ci vediamo al prossimo